we just have an absolute master class in  in-game technique by the world champion  himself how satisfied are you with this  impressive victory  um i thought i played relatively well i  was sort of drifting at some point when  i was moving my rook back and forth a  little bit because i realized my plan  didn't didn't work but i think  in general it's very hard for him to  hold and obviously  having that one point cushion already  makes it a lot  more comfortable  a couple of days ago you described your  play as decent is it fair to say that  you played better than decent today  no  okay  and uh you're standing in the tour is  now very comfortable were you surprised  by wesley's decision to accept a quick  draw with white yesterday  i didn't think about it too much okay  well you have a very good position and  we wish you the best of luck for the  rest of the tournament